a shooting rampage in Mississippi took
the lives of eight people including a
sheriff's deputy deputy William Duer was
killed Saturday after responding to what
was a domestic disturbance call the
suspect William Corey God bolt was
arrested after an all-night manhunt he
spoke to a local reporter with the
Clarion Ledger moments after he was
handcuffed the other seven victims are
reportedly members of gun bolts family
David Beck knows in Bogota Mississippi
at the home where the shootings began
David good morning Anthony good morning
the deputy was told there was an
unwanted guest who was here at this home
that guest turned out to be a family
member at some point it's believed the
deputy told a man you got to go and in
the process of leaving that man
allegedly pulled a weapon from his back
pocket shot and killed the deputy and
three other women at this home and then
his arrest was caught on camera officers
tackled and arrested the alleged killer
Willy God both following a multi home
killing spree he said deputy William
Dirar
was not his target the first shooting
happened around 11:30 p.m. Saturday at
this home where God bolts wife was
staying with the couple's two children
the wife had reportedly left him three
weeks ago somebody called the house he
could have been even little bit now
that's what they do they intervene in
addition to deputy derp Elise say God
Bolt killed three women at this home and
then fled over roughly the next six
hours God bolt allegedly killed four
more people at two other homes in
Lincoln County Mississippi once arrested
he said he wanted the police to kill him
Barbara Bui says her grandson Jordan
Blackwell was one of the victims we got
in vows and my my grandson was lying on
the floor when he wasn't on duty deputy
William Durr 36 was a ventriloquist who
had a knack for making children laugh he
was an amazing dad and husband officer
Kyle Brady who worked side by side with
Durr for many years made a promise
Tudor's Widow I told her we've got your
back if you ever need us here we are
deputy derived by his wife and a young
son
the alleged killer here did not shoot
his own wife or his children even though
they were all inside the home when the
killing spree started and vlad it's
worth noting when this all ended we're
told that there was a homeowner who
actually shot the suspect but then ended
up being killed by that suspect such a
tragic story David beg no thank you
David